SCOTT LANG
I just think you should get
to have a normal life.
CASSIE LANG
Dad, a guy dressed like a bee
tried to kill me in my
room when I was six.
YOUNG CASSIE LANG
Daddy is that you?
SCOTT LANG
Hi Peanut.
KATHRYN NEWTON
Cassie Lang wants to change the world.
CASSIE LANG
I have a suit.
[Yell]
SCOTT LANG
Yeah, I noticed.
KATHRYN NEWTON
She likes the chaos,
she wants to be fighting, and she
wants to be in the middle of it.
She's being influenced by these
superheroes around her.
CASSIE LANG
You know, if I had something like this
when you were gone,
I could've found you.
SCOTT LANG
Cassie!
CASSIE LANG
I'm sorry.
Dad!
PAUL RUDD
It was fun watching Kathryn
take on Cassie.
MICHELLE PFEIFFER
She just shows up and she's just got it.
JONATHAN MAJORS
The buoyant energy of her character
is so great.
KATHRYN NEWTON
She just wants to be a superhero
like her dad. She wants
to impress him.
SCOTT LANG
Momentum, right?  Jump, tap.
CASSIE LANG
I know how to do it, dad.
SCOTT LANG
Oh, do you?